foreign
most anticipated movies have you seen it
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one it's in theaters now and all week
we've been talking with the movie stars
for a mission impossible week the movie
is from Paramount Pictures part of the
same company as CBS go as we sat down
with actor Tom clementieff here in the
studio just yesterday she joins the
franchise as a ruthless and deadly Paris
she is tough in this clip from the movie
Paris Corners Tom Cruise's character
Ethan in a narrow Alleyway in Venice
Italy here's a look
um
[Music]
is your heart racing just looking at
that yes we are very happy to say first
on CBS mornings at Palm clementieff
joins us in studio and after looking at
that scene they say that people use half
of their chairs in the movie because
you're sitting at the edge of your seat
which is so true and that certainly is
one of those scenes we're told that
during that scene in particular you said
to Tom kick me kick me kick me harder
it's kind of true but I have to explain
okay so you understand the the thing is
I've been training for years and so I
know my distances and I know that if I
squeeze my abs I can take a hit so
that's why you do when you fight you
know yes and Tom is so trained and so
skilled and so good at action that he
could actually do it if he wanted to and
a little bit of contact in action movies
actually helps and makes it look more
real and it helps in the acting too
because if you hit me a little bit oh my
eyes are going to change and I'm going
to become a tiger so I was just asking
for that because I thought it would have
helped but he's such a gentleman that he
was like no no no Bob I'm not going to
hurt you I'm not going to hit you I was
like just just a little bit please no he
said no but this is what the director
says about you I love that little
antidote that you are a self-propelled
force of nature your nickname was Palm
Cruz yeah it's so physical but it is
fascinating your backstory you wanted
this role for a very long time that you
trained even when you didn't have the
role so it was my my dream to do action
movies but specifically Mission
Impossible because I think it's the best
of this genre you know it's more than
just an action movie I think it's art
you know and the level of excellence in
in everything in these movies is just
you know it's just mind-blowing so years
prior Mission Impossible even before
getting cast in gardens or a Galaxy Vol
2 I started training martial arts so
someone called Jessa novello taught me
how to cake how to punch uh how to do
stunts how to do that on camera and all
the tricks you know it takes years to be
good at something to be better you know
so you're always learning I'm still
learning now but
um back then I was training and even
sometimes in my schedule I would write
Mission Impossible in my phone instead
of writing martial arts training or
stunts it's manifesting it man yeah I
was manifesting though the whole time it
was like one day I maybe I get to do a
fighting with Tom who knows and you did
and he said kick me please uh the you
also Manifest this character Paris who
is she pursues Tom with a kind of
maniacal Glee I should say Ethan Hunt in
in the role and and I was reading that
you found inspiration for this predator
in animal videos but particular kinds of
animal videos right it was a stork of
some kind yeah no it's a crazy
prehistoric bird that looks crazy and I
like the way it moves and the look that
it has and in the movie as you know I
don't speak a lot so a lot of emotions
are conveyed with just body movement
face movement with just you know a kind
of like a rage boiling Under the Skin
and wanting to explode but like with no
words you know so this this particular
bird you have to Google it it's called
shoe bill or shoe belt sork I thought it
kind of looked like my character it
cannot look like me a little bit you do
manage
yeah you've got it for sure and and you
and Tom clearly have a deep respect and
a great working relationship now uh at
the premiere when he called introduced
you on stage they had a they had an
introduction for all the cast members uh
they were saying pom pom pom pom pom pom
pom pom pom pom using your first name
they call it Mission impalm Impossible
yeah
they were like doing that on when we
were shooting sometimes I would just
sing
come on guys you know what I would do
sometimes what
um before an action scene or
specifically before
um you know when I had to run on top of
a moving train it was going pretty fast
you know just and to remind myself what
I was doing and how happy I was to be
shooting this and to give me more
courage to do it it was like
yourself wow yes and then running on top
of the train
um uh jumping over carriages and and all
that I was reading that Tom as a kind of
a rap gift when you were done shooting
this film he gave you uh skydiving
lessons yes and you're using them yes
completely so he set it up for me which
was so kind and so generous and I
learned how to skydive I stayed there
for like 10 days I took lessons and um
and he did some jumps with me we did oh
yeah that was so much fun that's cool
and now I'm hooked and as soon as I have
some time off I go back to jump you must
be so psyched though about this movie
I'm so excited for all of you guys
everybody that's come here this week
because it's such an iconic movie and
now you will be associated with it
forever yeah I mean to go from someone
who dreamed about it to really that
coming true what does that mean to you
uh it's a it's a huge honor you know and
I'm I'm proud and I'm very happy to be
working with Incredible filmmakers like
Christopher mcquarie and Tom Cruise who
you know so so amazing to work with you
know and who inspire me every day so
yeah if you're lucky okay prom We are
cheering you on thank you thank you so
much thank you so much for being here
there's a music Mission possible dead
reckoning part one is out in theaters
now